the Asiatic honey bee pollinates the
mustard flowers in Nepal's Western Hill
Country the region's farmers depend on
it they get their cooking oil from
mustard seeds hollowed-out tree trunks
service hives they cost nothing and are
virtually maintenance-free these have
been kept like this for generations
these mean a lot to me they give us
honey which has healing powers and we
can earn a little money by selling the
Chiura tree could scarcely survive
without the Asiatic honeybee the tree
provides important protection from
landslides during the rainy season
Bharata pour about 600 kilometres away
Nepal's fifth largest city lies in the
Terai the belt of lowlands in the south
of the country
away from the roads bees swarm here as
well but they're not Asiatic honeybees
their apis mellifera their European
cousins they were introduced into Nepal
in the 1990s and have displaced the
Asiatic honeybee in the lowlands
biologists umma pop wants to protect the
indigenous species a representative of
the Nepalese Beekeepers Association
gives his point of view from European
honeybees 9 to 10 times a year the yield
is greater so beekeepers prefer that
species but there are other reasons the
European honeybee has won out over its
Asian counterpart infectious diseases
initially perhaps a lot of diseases have
been got transferred from utopian
honeybee to Asian honeybee mostly these
brood diseases say for example European
foul brood which is really causing
problems with Asian honeybee back to the
western hills the winter is still mild
because European honeybees can't
tolerate temperatures under the freezing
point they won't be found here I'm a
part app is already expected she'll be
giving a workshop on modern beekeeping
an isolated village for organization the
International Center for integrated
mountain development wants to improve
the lives of people in the mountainous
regions and preserve diversity of
species without the income from selling
honey
farmers would have a hard time surviving
here
but keeping bees in hollowed-out tree
trunks isn't a very efficient method the
honeycombs have to be painstakingly torn
out of the log and the process of
extracting the honey destroys them the
honey that is extracted contains the
parts of brood or adult bees many bees
get killed also so the quality of honey
is not so good
and also the colony also gets weaker how
can the bees be protected from disease
what methods bring the best yields the
bee expert knows very well that
protecting the bees must be financially
worthwhile so she promotes modern box
Ives the brood is kept in the lower part
where it's protected the removable
honeycomb contains only adult bees and
the honey and there's another advantage
they can be reused again for these to
store more honey so the bees do not have
to spend more energy to the new house to
store the hives are good now we're able
to see whether or not the colony is
diseased honey is being made and how the
brood is doing a bit lower in the hill
country in the village of Judge Judah
the new method has long since
established itself the bees accept the
hives in the colonies which had been
under threat are growing again
thirty-year-old come on abou hotter also
benefits
she used to earn her living just from
farming now she has her own Carpenters
workshop she specializes in building
beehives
and it's doubled her income building
honeycomb frames and box hives has
become very important for us since
modern beekeeping was introduced in this
region the demand is so great that we
can hardly keep up buchanan's I guess
henna kumano also sells entire bee
colonies and she's a beekeeper herself
here she's harvesting the last honey of
the season come on I used to keep bees
using traditional methods
now she simply spins out the honeycomb
frames which can then be used again
that's good for the bees and good for
the honey it never used to be as pure as
it is now
gosh I didn't hurt our diner I did